yesterday CNN once again became that
nosy detestable neighbor Gladys from
bewitched who gins up phony concern only
to spread malicious gossip about the
first lady's whereabouts
check out this tweet from our nation's
hall monitor brian Stelter if any first
lady disappeared you'd want to know
where she is
see what he did there to justify the
odious premise he first had to create
the premise if any first lady
disappeared and so begins a Trojan horse
for a ghoulish game all to push a phony
CNN segment see instead of saying is
Milania missing they pitched their
segment as how the media is covering
milania's absence so they're covering
how they're covering it I guess we
should cover how they're covering how
they're covering it one thing that the
president the White House have been
quite quiet about is Melania Trump and
her status we did see her tweet the
other day but the first time we've
caught a glimpse of her the last time we
caught a glimpse of her was on Marta May
10th I wonder if somebody's guiding that
kind of that kind of tweet from her that
doesn't seem like her at least the image
she's had in her engagement with the
president if the first lady or the
person who's standing in for first lady
disappears you want to know where she is
uh-uh clouds they even had a chart how
sophisticated and so this speculation
fueled endless guessing games on Twitter
the pleasure many found in hoping
something was wrong with the first lady
and then cloaking it as some kind of
concern Dwarfs any of the jokes with the
c-word
CNN HuffPo Newsweek trumpets deranged
these ghouls to a point that they barely
have any humanity left just when you
think you hit the bottom of the cesspool
more cesspool some even suggested that
Trump beat Melania trapped in their own
prison of pain since 2016 their misery
only seeks company i square jeff zucker
must be spinning in his grave if he
wasn't alive and well
or is he has anyone seen him see what I
did there
Dana this is what people do on Sundays I
mean there were actually people sitting
around tweeting about if Trump beats his
Trump beat Melania remember when the
media was really upset about any
questions about Hillary Clinton's health
during the campaign and that that was
out of bounds
but there was yes actually she did faint
yes yes I've been she was trying to get
into that van and that was out of bounce
and she wanted to be the President of
the United States the first lady does
not have any you know she's not an
elected person she can do whatever she
wants I hope that she's well and it
would be it would be more believable if
they really cared how she was yeah yeah
I don't think they care that's the thing
that gets me Jessie is the camouflage
right we're just you know we're just
worried about her no you're not you
don't even like last week they were
making all sorts of disgusting
commentary and now they're so concerned
about her health the media is spending
more time wondering where Melania is and
not wondering where Isis is do you think
they'd spill some ink over that I mean
Trump made Isis disappear Melania hasn't
gone anywhere let's focus on that
Peter Strock went missing they haven't
shove the camera in peter Strock face it
would seem like the media might want to
get some answers about his whereabouts
she had kidney surgery three weeks ago
it's an incredibly invasive and delicate
procedure I'm sure she wants to come
back on her own terms at her own time
and that's fine but Trump's marriages
have always been subject to tabloid
father people fodder they speculate you
know it's good ink people profit off of
it it's good for cliques and she's not
the most you know she doesn't speak a
lot publicly so there's a vacuum there
and she doesn't have a robust PR machine
so they fill the void with these
speculations and the narratives that
have no connection to reality and I
think it just it shows the disrespect to
the first family last time it was Ivanka
then Melania this week you know they
don't respect them like they used to in
him you know one is this just another
example of having because there's just
so much good news who's got a right you
got to go after the first lady because
she might be recuperating or maybe she
just likes to do whatever the hell she
wants right you know maybe she just
doesn't want to feel good I don't know I
I don't follow tour the way you do but I
don't know that there's any antipathy
toward her I just haven't seen that I
think they made fun of her accent
remember 200 people have said that bad
and I think people have questioned you
know her health you know be kiddin know
much about this and now subsequently but
anybody who's sick I mean if you have to
have some sympathy for them the big
question here is she's supposed to have
an event today I think it's for gold
star families and and they close it to
the press so at some point when you're
in power and you start to keep the press
out the press is like hey what's going
on and I think that's what you're
getting but you want to attack the press
for this I just think you know what if
the White House was transparent and said
you know what the lady he is 48 she had
surgery and she wants to have a rest
period I think everybody in America
would say god bless or hope she's
recovering well but not it's not not the
people you haven't looked at the tweets
rep they talked about her getting beaten
up I don't know you said conserve is why
is anybody even saying that because
they're awful people and I won't even
mention their names because they're
there beneath they will not be mentioned
on the five but you can look them up
Kimberly yeah I just think it's really
disrespectful obviously this was a
serious you know medical condition she
had to get this a kidney embolization so
it was at Walter Reed perhaps she needs
some time to be able to recover and get
back on her feet you know she has a very
stressful job because she's not treated
well in the press to begin with so
there's an emotional and psychological
strain to begin with and now a physical
toll on her body and she's you know a
mother of a young son and so she's gonna
spend time as well with him quite
worried about you know his mom so what
is the point here they acted like she
was like a missing person saying like
it's just crazy this White House is the
most transparent thing in the history of
history I mean we know everything well
they make it they make fun of it for
being like a reality show then when they
when they think that this is part of the
act right they're like oh they're hiding
Melania from you so you can't see her so
now that has to become part of the
storyline or something and feign that
they're concerned yeah they're not
actually concerned at all they cared
they would respect privacy and let her
get better instead of making a mockery
of it like she's a missing person's
alert on a milk carton